cashback gern wenn es brennt
na na na hallo leute ich es wieder eure
mal waren willkommen zu einer neuen
folge wie schmeckt's nachdem meine
analytics nämlich steinberg runter
gegangen sind weil ich immer noch in dem
geheim super geheim mega geheim super
projekt involviert bin muss ich jetzt
meine existenz fürchten und dachte ich
komme heute mal wieder mit einem ganz
großen brüder und zwar das ratatouille
aus ratatouille ihr habt euch das
tatsächlich gewünscht seitdem ich mir
schmeckt eingeführt erfunden habe und
natürlich klar
ich darf ja ich habe eine ziege gehört
und damit meine damen und herren fahre
ich den faden verloren
da isser ja wünschen ihm ist ein
bisschen rücksicht mit mir haben ich bin
noch nicht wieder drin in dem video
making flora wie jetzt nicht auf das
video geklickt ob ich meine lines
geschichte anzuhören sondern um ein
richtig heißes sollte ich jetzt immer so
tragen und ich hatte geburtstag und
haben ganz tolles geburtstagsgeschenk
bekommen und zwar die mich am heute die
kitchen queen man es ahnen
ich bin die kitchen green und ich
regiere über diese küche ich habe zeit
von koch mit saftig fühlen auch nicht
ganz so diesen spirit wisst was ich
meine ich muss einfach mehr wieso eine
rasse denken in dem film geht es darum
eine ratte direkt
gut kochen kann und dieses ratatouille
auch zubereitet diese folge entwickelt
sich brüderlich dabei wollte ich doch
jetzt super ernst wer kommen wir zu den
zutaten wir brauchen grüne zucchini
gelbe zucchini und die habe ich sehr
lange gesucht denn die gibt es nicht in
normalen supermärkten nein die gibt es
nur im großen edeka center oder in
irgendwelchen riesen leben aber da
findet man sie auf jeden fall nach
tomaten und auberginen und dann gibt es
ganz unterschiedliche auberginen und
zwar ist das eine normale und ist eine
japanische und die eignet sich besser
wenn man solchen schneiden will und
braucht nicht nur gemüse was wir so
übereinander fächern sondern auch eine
rote soße die diese kleine ratte da so
vorher auf schmiert und ich dachte mir
paprika ist ganz super und ich dafür
nehmen wir doch mal gegrillte paprika
aus dem werks denn die reine kulisse
junger dann brauchen wir noch eine
zwiebel und knoblauch und zu guter letzt
thymian und rosmarin ich bin mir nicht
ganz sicher was ist die kenner wenn
jetzt sagen uns falsch aber ich habe
hier eigenen thymian aus dem garten und
deswegen benutze ich und natürlich wie
immer salz und pfeffer und olivenöl
wir fangen ganz simpel land und zwar mit
einer zwiebel zahn thema maschine
wir schneiden zu ersten mal kann man ja
auch so ne demo somit meter schneien
ganz dünne streifen die dümmsten
streifen eures lebens
[Musik]
schnell der kritiker kommen wir müssen
das beste gerichtes von drachen war ist
das spannend wenn ich das aber vorspulen
sitzen raus oder bist du vollständig
schneiden würde oder ok aubergine ist
dann was fehlt noch
gamestar kimi und dass wir nicht sehen
können wie ich das glück in dieser
branche hart und das wird immer mehr
songs echte gelbe zucchini die soll wenn
ihr nicht gut schmeckt es hat so lange
dauert die zu finden
und jetzt noch eine schöne dicke grüne
zitrone
jetzt kümmern wir uns um die soße dafür
kommt alles in einen mixer wie gesagt
die soße soll nicht allzu kompliziert
werden
ein mann soll sich auch an das gericht
herantrat und nicht sagen das ist mir zu
schwer abtropfgewicht halt wenn es
abgetropft ist oder das was da drin ist
320 gramm haben wir mal gute 300 gramm
zu den paprikas kommen wir zum eine
zwiebel und wenn ihm eine zwiebel heck
video gesehen habt dann wisst ihr dass
ich jetzt richtiger profi
und natürlich wieder keine tipps anfang
aber bei roten zwiebel dass es nicht so
schlimm und knoblauch in die schüssel
für die schärfe kommt jetzt bunter
pfeffer ein halber teelöffel und ein
bisschen salz und ein bisschen
gemüsebrühe weil durch gemüsebrühe
schmeckt alles besser natürlich auch
noch zwei bis drei esslöffel olivenöl
rein da ich koche bei wie schmeckt so
selten ob ich mal auf so selten wie
schmeckt in letzter zeit ich koche aber
bei mir schmeckt so sänken herzhafte
gerichte also richtige mahlzeiten nimmt
schließlich motoren und süßkram und so
muss es sieht so lecker aus manche
sagten schaut man an und man weiß schon
wie es schmecken wird strom zb jetzt
nixon werden diese delicious
[Musik]
warum werden rote paprika mix orange wir
machen für die süße noch ein budget
catcher bereit
[Musik]
ok jetzt habe eigentlich alles schon
gemacht was sie machen müssen
so einfach ist das jetzt brauchen eine
auflaufform so was macht der endeten
löffel und verstreicht es zu spielen
jetzt beginnt wirklich der sehr
komplizierte partie also aubergine gelbe
zucchini tomaten und dann gering
das muss man eigentlich von innen nach
außen machen ich muss jetzt einfach wäre
wann es so ein bisschen angeber essen
eigentlich ist glaube ich nicht so
schwierig schlimm ich ein bisschen an
aber es geht voll schick aus freddys zu
sehen excuse me
das ist schon mal gar nicht so schlecht
ich habe nur ein bisschen zu viel gemüse
das ist aber kein problem denn das kann
man ja immer noch einfach anbraten und
mit reis essen oder man hat sich einfach
von anfang an eine größere auflaufform
vielleicht eine wo man auf so ein
bisschen länger gehen kann und nicht so
nur ein kreis ist wir sind dabei uns gar
nicht schlimm dass noch mit sich offen
wir müssen so ein kreis aufschneiden den
wir drauflegen können
denn zu machen dass die köche biebers
drauf habe
die von oben stecken können kommt nach
thymian oder rosmarin rüber wie kameras
und stadtrat macht es dann noch aroma in
dieser saft deckel drauf und in den ofen
damit so und das ist jetzt für eine
unbestimmte zeit der proben liegen
ich denke mal so 20 minuten und dann
sehen wir uns gleich wieder mit einer
sauberen küche es fertig aber sieht
nicht ganz das original
aber egal aber ich habe neue hochschul
und endlich mal ofen handschuhe deswegen
hoffe ich dass die jetzt gut
funktioniert es wird interessant aus es
riecht auf jeden fall super lecker wer
immer schon mal sehen wollte wie ich mir
die hände verbrennen jetzt seine chance
ich habe aber einen keks aus still
jetzt habe ich echt lust auf kleine aber
damit können wir so ein stab immer dann
läuft die soße nicht zu den regen doch
dort muss man natürlich noch so die soße
so elegant wie möglich
[Musik]
die waren ja auch mal ganz frei nach ein
bisschen vögel noch weiter aus dem
garten bisschen thymian und nun stellen
uns natürlich wieder der
allerwichtigsten frage wie schmeckt das
ratatouille aus katar tui holt
luxusschiff muss eigentlich jede schicht
gleichzeitig also tomate gelbe zucchini
aubergine und grüne
[Musik]
wow
er schmeckt so lecker
ich fühle mich richtig in meine kindheit
zurückversetzt damals in der provence
als meine mama mia ratatouille gemacht
hatten wir mal wieder das knie
aufgeschlagen hat hmm wie kann gemüse so
gut schmecken
aber ich will ganz so gerne noch einen
ruck banken mit dem ganzen dinge ich
würde es komplett verschlingen ich bin
sprachlos
das war sehr lecker ich hoffe es hat die
folge gefallen
das ist ein bisschen komisch mal wieder
vor der kamera gestanden zu haben ich
wäre dabei bestimmt schnell wieder
reinkommen und damit sei es bis zum
nächsten mal hier noch zwei weitere
videos ich hoffe euch das video gefallen
wenn jahren sei es nun unbedingt einen
daumen nach oben
tut mir leid für ein bisschen verwirrt
war aber es ist schwierig nicht so lang
voll kamera stand zu haben ihr internet
zeit ist so eine woche ein jahr im
reallife gefühlt ich hab schon alles
verpasst
die ganzen trends wie zum beispiel die
robbe macht die rockgruppe macht dir ob
du bist dann ist das ganze ding auf ich
brauche mir das nicht fern sie auf den
teller legen nicht fotos einfach weg